Let's now talk a little bit about web content
distribution networks or CDNs. We'll first talk about what
a CDN is and why a content provider might
want to use one. We'll then talk about how service
selection works in CDNs and how clients get redirected
to the right server. So first of all, what is
a content distribution network? It's an overlay network of
web caches that's designed to deliver content to a client
from the optimal location. Now, in many
cases, optimal means geographically closest but, sometimes,
optimal is not the geographically closest cache
and we'll see some examples of when that's
the case. CDNs are made of distinct
geographically disparate groups of servers, where each group
can serve all the content on the CDN. These CDNs can often be quite extensive.
Here is a global map depicting the
deployment of the Google cache servers, around
the world. As mapped in a recent
project, by researchers at the University of Southern
California. As you can see, these Web caches can be quite extensive and in many
cases there's a concerted effort to place
caches as close as possible to users. Some
CDNs are owned by content providers such as Google and others are owned and
operated by networks such as Level 3, Limelight and AT&T. Still others such
as Akami operate independently. Non network CDNs, such as Akami and Google, can
typically place servers in other autonomous systems
or ISPs. The number of cache nodes
ind a large content distribution network can vary. For example, in the Google
Network, the USC researchers found that there
were about 30,000 unique front-end cache nodes.
As of about two years ago, the Akamai Edge platform reported about 85,000
unique caching servers, in nearly 1,000 unique
networks around the world, in 72 countries.